foreign
[Music]
code can improve your workflow
we the people in this room and our
friends joining online we know this
but writing code can also be tricky
frustrating and time consuming we also
know this
and in my experience it can be difficult
to give in to yourself or maybe a
manager that it is worth spending time
up front to write code for tasks like
data wrangling especially if there's an
existing process that's already good
enough
so my goal today is to demonstrate that
it is worth spending this time up front
to write code because in the long run it
will save time reduce errors and improve
the workflow
and I'm going to use some examples from
my work and maybe these will motivate
you to go off and write some code
or maybe you can use these examples to
help convince a skeptical manager to let
you write that code
so hi everyone my name is Danielle
Dempsey I'm a research scientist at a
small company called the center for
marine applied research or cmar for
short in Nova Scotia Canada
CMR coordinates this really great
Coastal monitoring program to measure
ocean variables like temperature
dissolved oxygen and salinity from all
around the coast of the province
this data can be used by scientists to
study Coastal ecosystems
industry to inform their site selection
government to inform their policy and
management decisions and the list could
go on
so this is really valuable data
but
for several years it was rarely used
because it was just stored on somebody's
desktop and a myriad of CSV and Excel
files that were really difficult and
time consuming to compile into a useful
format
so why was this so difficult
it has to do with how the data are
collected using what we call sensor
strings
so a sensor string consists of a rope
that's anchored to the ocean floor and
suspended just below the surface by a
buoy
there are sensors attached to the Rope
at different depths through the water
column
and these sensors are recording data
every one minute to one hour
each sensor string is deployed in one
location for a couple of months up to a
year so they're really collecting a lot
of data
and we use three different types of
sensors that each report the data back
in a slightly different format like you
can see on the screen
and you can start to appreciate how
working with this data can be
challenging especially because there can
be seven or more sensors on each sensor
string and each of these data files can
be tens of thousands of rows long
so part of the reason that I was hired
about two years ago was to help compile
all of this data into a nice tidy format
that we could post online for any
interested stakeholder to download and
use in their own analyzes
so about three weeks after I started
this new position I had a video call
with my manager so she could show me how
show me the existing process for how
this data is compiled
and I can remember very vividly sitting
in my home office on a beautiful
Thursday afternoon while she showed me
this process
and let me tell you
this involved copying
it involved pasting it involves sorting
the data by a specific column and it
even involved writing down the Excel row
numbers to use later on in the process
it was truly horrible
and I thought to myself I will never do
that
I offered to write some code to help
with this but my manager was a little
bit skeptical at first particularly
because at this point I wasn't very
confident in my data wrangling or
package development skills
but eventually she gave me the thumbs up
and I wrote a package called strings to
help automate a lot of this process
to be clear the package is named after
our sensor strings and has nothing to do
with character strings so this was maybe
a bit of a naive name choice but it's
only caused one small moment of
confusion so far and that's another
story
for now I'll move on to my first point
writing code will save you time
yes you'll have to spend some time up
front to develop the code and you may
have some learning curves to surmount
particularly if you're new to R new to
coding
but it will be worth it
so I spent a few
um
a few weeks developing the backbone of
the strings package
and as I said at this time I didn't have
a lot of experience with data wrangling
package development working with dates
and times or importing and exporting
large data files
so I spent a pretty substantial amount
of time looking into different packages
to help with those challenges
and these are just some of the packages
that I ended up working with you'll
recognize most of them from the tiny
verse although there are a couple from
outside of that collection
and the point I want to make here is
that even though I hadn't used most of
these packages before working on strings
I now use almost all of them in almost
all of my coding projects and that's
because of the time that I spent
learning about them to work on the
strings package
so this is just one small example of how
the skills that you learn working on one
coding project are often really
transferable to other projects
and in my case the time that I spent
working on the strings package also
saved us time for processing that
Coastal monitoring program data
we estimate that it would have taken two
years of work hours to compile all of
that data with the horrendous old copy
and paste method
instead within a couple of months I had
developed the package myself and our
student at the time had compiled and
formatted all of the data posted online
and generated summary reports through
our markdown
it's also now really easy to train new
people to compile this data using
templates that I wrote to go with the
package
our current intern has compiled 71
deployments so far
in on top of all of his other work in
just the 11 weeks that he's been with us
so far
that's something that would have taken
over nine months of dedicated work time
with the old method
and on the screen is just a tiny tiny
snapshot of our data so this is
temperature data from six deployments or
about four years from an area called
Bertie head
and here temperature was measured at
seven different depths through the water
column which are shown by color
and if you're interested in this or any
other CMR data feel free to find me
later this afternoon I'm always really
happy to talk about it
writing code to help with your data
wrangling can also help find and reduce
errors in your data set
this will give you and your clients more
confidence in the data and also make
whatever analysis you plan on doing with
that data more reliable
and in my experience errors can kind of
creep into the data at different points
along the data pipeline especially
wherever humans are involved
and so I've learned to write code to
anticipate and sometimes even fix those
those errors
I have two examples of that for you
for the first one after we had finished
compiling all that sensor string data I
decided to plot the latitude and
longitude of each sensor string to get
an idea of the spatial coverage of the
data
so you can imagine my surprise when my
map looks something like this
so most of the sensor strings are
showing up clustered around Nova Scotia
which is what we would expect
but there's also some Center strings
showing up way over here in Kazakhstan
which is not close to Nova Scotia and
not even anywhere near the ocean
so what's going on here after a little
bit of digging I discovered that our
contractors who actually deploy these
sensor strings have to manually record
the latitude and longitude of each
location
and because Nova Scotia is in the
Western Hemisphere longitude is
typically recorded as a negative value
but every so often it accidentally gets
entered as a positive value which is
what's causing some of these sensor
strings to show up way over there in
Central Asia
so now when the package first reads in
this coordinate data I'll get a warning
if any of those longitude values are
positive so we can go in and fix that
mistake before compiling all the data
a kind of more Insidious error that I've
seen is data from the wrong uh the wrong
sensor in a file of data that's ready to
be compiled
and this just happens when someone has
what I call a human moment and
accidentally puts the wrong file in the
folder
in this example data from one of the
sensors on the blue sensor string has
been put in the folder with all of the
data from sensors on the green sensor
string
and this issue was really twofold
one the data set for the blue sensor
string will be incomplete and two we
will get false information about the
area where the green sensor string was
deployed
so this is really a critical error to be
able to find and fix
luckily the data files are automatically
named with the serial number of the
sensor
and we keep track of which sensors are
associated with each sensor string in
deployment logs
and so I've written code in the package
that will give an error if there's any
missing extra or different files in that
folder based on what we would expect
from the log
writing code to help automate your data
wrangling can also make your workflow
more traceable and reproducible
especially when compared to something
like copying and pasting
and you can explain this to your
non-coding managers with a metaphor
so copying and pasting in Excel is kind
of like making a salad from just
whatever is left in your fridge
most of the time it will probably taste
okay
but eventually you will get something
that doesn't taste quite right
and because you have no record of what
went into that salad it's really hard to
tell what exactly is making it taste
funny
and it's also hard to avoid making the
same mistake in the future
as my colleague said when I was trying
this metaphor out on her you can't take
the dressing back out of the salad
in contrast writing code is more like
writing and following a recipe
you can follow it step by step to get a
delicious salad every time
and as an added bonus you can even give
this recipe to a friend so they can make
their own salad
or help you make dinner
as a more concrete example for another
part of our Coastal monitoring program
we had these 65 current data sets that
had to be compiled from a kind of messy
text format into a tidier CSV format
that was easier to work with
so I offered to write some code to help
with this
but my managers again decided to have a
couple of people instead copy paste and
format in Excel
this took hours and hours of several
people's time
but eventually they finished
and then
we discovered that there had been a
small mistake in how these original text
files were exported from the sensor
software
so all of the data needed to be compiled
again
so this time I was asked to write some
code
and within a few weeks I had written a
package that automated most of this
workflow
so now if we want to make any other
changes to this process we've actually
made a couple I just need to go in tweak
the code press a button and all of this
data will be compiled within just a few
minutes
and so if you have a repetitive task
that you've been thinking about
automating I encourage you to go home
after the conference and start writing
some code
you don't have to write a whole package
in a day you can start with a function
or two and just see where it goes from
there
and if you do get some pushback from a
skeptical manager remind them that
writing code will save time reduce
errors and improve the workflow
and if you do use those points and it
works please let me know because it
would make my day
and the last thing I'll say is that my
previously skeptical manager is now
totally on board and really supportive
of all my coding
she even sewed me this super r
because she says that I've convinced her
that R can do anything that we put our
minds to
so thank you and happy coding
[Applause]
[Music]